hey everyone the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is now facing its biggest
change ever now that Disney's purchase
and merger of Fox Studios is official
how will this affect the Marvel lineup
Avengers 4 and Beyond and the announced
Fox Marvel properties like Deadpool
x-men Dark Phoenix and New Mutants and
x-force well we'll get to the MCU future
but first welcome to new rockstars news
it's our deep dive and all the biggest
stories this week so we're also gonna
talk about the new Iron Fist trailer a
possible villain for spider-man far from
home some Easter eggs in the upcoming
spider-man ps4 game and the new watchman
series on HBO Merrick Valastro made this
table mr. Sam bashful peace a boy here
yeah we ordered a pizza and Sam was here
and we talked down to him so much we
know it's a boy with the it balloon here
yum yum and welcome back again it has
been a minute since you've been able to
host with us but it wasn't the same yeah
I'm so sorry but I'm excited I'm ready
to talk about it especially Iron Fist
let's get into it let's get into it and
well we could start with our top story
the marvels now official merger with the
Fox Marvel Universe thanks to the
approved deal for Disney to purchase all
of Fox's film and TV properties which
include Deadpool in the x-men and the
Fantastic Four and let's start by
talking timeline here so what this means
for the upcoming movies that we've been
anticipating so it looks like Disney
still plans to release the Fox movies
that were completed or in the middle of
production at the time of acquisition so
that includes x-men Dark Phoenix which
still has a release date of February
14th 2019 and the New Mutants which was
originally set to come out last April
but was moved back to August 2nd 2019
just go yeah go keep going keep going
yeah and we've had a trailer for that
too like we don't have Enix yeah we had
a full trailer that was actually the
first episode of the show that we did
was breaking down that trailer
now there's also other movies that were
rumored or at least being developed on
the Fox side of things like dr. doom or
gambit
like Channing Tatum attached a Silver
Surfer movie was in the works but those
will probably not happen or maybe
they'll be reworked when things move
over to Disney none of those were even
finished script wise or started shooting
yet so those aren't going to happen but
the question is is how this will affect
x-force the follow-up to Deadpool to
director Drew Goddard was supposed to
begin shooting this October but it
sounds like if this you know if they
stick to this he might have missed the
boat there however this week the
Deadpool movie Twitter account tweeted a
recruitment poster taking applications
to join the x-force and suggesting movie
that this movie might still be happening
right or maybe Ryan Reynolds is just
using social media to keep x-force from
getting overlooked during this
transition because that's essentially
how we got the first step whole movie
made is just like went on social media
and in crowd funded the whole not crowd
funded but crowd-sourced the whole
excitement for that but now I'm thinking
like when it comes to the upcoming in
2019 Marvel movies Captain Marvel
Avengers for spider-man far from home
this merger doesn't necessarily mean
that we'll see a bunch of x-men save the
day in those movies it's you know it's a
little too soon I Captain Marvel and
Avengers 4 have wrapped in principal
production and the story for spider-man
2 is pretty set at this point now the
turnaround time on these big-budget
movies is roughly three years so we
should expect any Disney Marvel x-men
movies until 2022 at the soonest though
you know since all those movies do go
through reshoots months after the fact
it could be fun to include like a short
Deadpool cameo in a post-credits scene
or just like a flash of him do you think
the Disney and Marvel should fully
integrate all the x-men and Deadpool and
cable and the Fantastic Four into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe - well the
other characters are or could it be
worth it for Disney maybe to keep some
of them produced by like a separate sub
studio to maintain the edgier brand that
Deadpool has carved out I guess maybe
what was Disney's more adult branch oh
touchstone yeah I wish is not having
hopefully blinked twice if you guys are
okay I haven't heard their apartment
yeah he smells something that I call
somebody uh no I thought you'd be they
Disney does have more adult brands or
properties that they could kind of
shuffle these properties over to kinda
like
Warner Brothers they did that with their
new line with Shazam so they have
another production house that's working
on it doesn't quite change much that's
actually a little bit different but I
could see them taking like Deadpool are
there more adult properties like x-force
cuz clearly like that set up to be
r-rated and you should do it that way
because that's the precedent that you
said so yeah go ahead and go with that
but when it comes to integrating the
rest into the MCU I feel like you could
like I remember doctor who had a kind of
like this like unspoken rule about how
their multiple shows would cross over
each other with each other that your
r-rated characters could come over to
the younger shows like Doctor Who but
they couldn't go to the like Sarah Jane
Chronicles because that was meant for a
young kids Oh doctor could go down to
Sarah Jane and cross over there and
Sarah Jane can come to Doctor Who doctor
it was like no-man's land or but that
was free for all everyone go there but
none of the other characters could go up
to Torchwood that had those like more
adult-themed like sexy more violent
storylines which I thought was kind of
interesting in a way to kind of like
keep your audiences safe and not keep
complaints from people right so I feel
like there's a way to have characters
from the r-rated properties kind of show
up and use their r-rated storytelling
and comedy and humor to may be like kind
of freshen up the Avengers movies in
some way but for every other x-men
character in Fantastic Four throw them
in the 8th row I'm gonna mix yeah and
it's time for a reboot I think for some
of those for sure absolutely fantastic
you know it's interesting like I feel
like it would be odd to see Deadpool
show up in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
Avengers saga as we know it right now
his humor just feels like it's cut from
a completely different cloth and like
there are funny wisecracking characters
in the MCU that I feel like Deadpool
would be in a weird conflict like
tonally speaking but what I love about
like the Deadpool comics is it is part
of the Marvel Universe in the comics and
you do see spider-man you do see other
characters show up in Deadpool's worlds
and hopefully what this means they'll be
able to continue making Deadpool movies
just have a much more interesting pool
of characters to pull in and team-up
with them and join so it's not just you
know
Wolverine cameos and in Charles Xavier
cameos yeah negasonic teenage warhead
another obscure boy it might have Iron
Man show up and just be like
leave me alone you know yeah yeah I'd be
on board and also I feel like a lot of
those actors would be on board with
playing with those characters as well
which would be really cool and you and
maybe moving forward kind of how DC's
like we're just still in movies now
don't worry it's not like a connected
thing Marvel might be doing the same
thing we don't know cuz like they
planned for this and like they set up
this that doesn't mean they can't go
forward there's plenty of videos on this
channel that you could watch right there
are some amazing ideas of what they
could do but also if they wanted to kind
of split it up and be like we still want
to tell stories with these characters
and we don't want it to actually mean
anything to the rest of the world now
Black Panther was where it's kind of it
it will affect but it's more a deal it's
more personal
you could have a brand through Disney or
through touchstone earth through or it
keep using Fox and keep using that Tyler
we're like our Fox movies are more
violent yeah also Fox owns like alien
and stuff so like I don't do they own
alien they're in Avatar movies yeah it's
interesting because I think the
perception is Oh Fox has kind of blown
it and like Marvel has to come and say
that if Fox has been a very successful
studio and these franchises have been
great the reason why they sold to Disney
is they're just looking further down the
line intensity has their own streaming
service that's gonna compete with
Netflix and Fox is like well we don't
the infrastructure to really compete
with that the way that like Comcast
might because Comcast also owns the
distribution of how like your content
gets to you and Fox doesn't really have
that as much so they're probably like
well we've never been more valuable than
we are right now let's just go ahead and
sell and make as much bang for our buck
as we can and make Comcast and Disney go
in a bidding war for us so we can get
what is it seventy one point three
billion yeah so I think it's not that
like Fox do anything wrong it's still a
very successful very productive studio
that I think should be kept intact like
I'm sure Disney I'm not gonna tell these
like studio execs out to do this because
I'm sure they already know but hopefully
they keep some version of Fox intact so
that they can continue to not only
produce these three movies that are in
the pipeline two to three movies they're
in the pipeline but continue producing
some movies that are just part of this
brand the way they can just keep Fox's
like a touchstone you know what is
interesting is because as far as we knew
as people who are not involved with the
purchase or sale of these giant studios
but as people who just hear about a
report on it one of the early talks was
that
Fox News brand was gonna be its own
thing somewhere else I don't know if
that's it still is Fox News was not part
of the purchase okay there yes so that's
interesting so that with that if because
Disney has it leans more left instead of
like right like with what Fox News's
brand is saying this is not getting
political but it's like if Disney owned
that and it kind of wanted to make it a
little bit more like its own brand I
feel like they would try to like change
the name a little bit but keep the idea
of Fox is a studio that you own now and
you can use to make more adult stories
but maybe no one call Fox because that's
Fox over there now like that Fox and now
you're something else now yeah they
might just come up with some kind of new
name that yeah the name isn't that
important it was just an idea that just
came to my head no but that is an
interesting point it's you know Kevin
Feige has said that like there is room
for an r-rated superhero movie in the
Marvel 10 it can't be a big ten but it's
gonna have to require them to change the
game I I think you know within our
bubble we're often just talking about
how big a deal is this but it really is
going to change the whole MCU as we know
it because as soon as Avengers 4 happens
space war we don't know anything about
this is uncharted territory that we're
going into so yeah we may see not just
like two different sides to this
universe we could see several different
smaller brands that they're gonna pursue
and just see which ones are the most
successful because once you've finished
up this Avengers story unless you
continue with like legacy characters or
something like that what is next you
have you know guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 which who knows what's happenin
there oops and then you have more
spider-man movies and hopefully more
black panther and Doctor Strange movies
but yeah I think it might be wise for
Disney to not just have Fox as its own
kind of side of their universe but have
other things that they just rather than
just having two things that are in
competition with each other have like
everything kind of split off in its own
direction and just see which one is the
most and as far as I know ya know
you got a good point because also like
the Marvel TV stuff is already kind of
in its own world which to other people's
dismay me I wish it was more connected
but you know yeah yeah and it's
interesting is we're also talking about
shows like Legion which are part of the
Fox side of things now are gonna be like
joining the Disney World and I don't
want any of these shows to have to like
change their brand or anything
to become more family-friendly or more
or broader or you know more universally
appealing because I think that's one
thing that Fox has done a little bit
better than some of these other
superhero brands it's like trying out
being a bit more experimental yeah if
you consider something like Logan or
Deadpool to be experiments that
definitely paid off and I don't want to
see more of that more experimentation
totally speaking 100% well I'm on board
yeah let us know what you think in the
comments below are you hoping that
Deadpool can maintain his identity are
you worried that he's gonna have to
change who he is is there a version of
Deadpool that could exist and stay the
same should he appear in Avengers movies
or should Avengers appear in his movies
light up the comments below and end
tweet us both ok guys a new trailer for
Netflix is iron fist just dropped and
the footage is definitely getting fans
excited so let's break down the big
details that you need to know from this
trailer the trailer focuses largely on
the villain Davos aka steel serpent he's
played by Sacha Diwan Davos takes Danny
Rance gee it seems with a glowing red
fist of his own if you look closely
you'll notice that Danny's hand never
appears to be lit up when Davos fights
him with his red fist
so maybe Davos stole the Chi from Danny
or maybe he got it through some other
means like notice on the show that we
also see some shot of a decomposing
corpse with an iron fist mask and
perhaps that could be the body of Orson
Randall or there's also another shot of
the iron fist brand on a cut of
parchment which could be human skin and
I'm thinking maybe maybe Davos tore this
off of the corpses chest yeah I get some
version of the chief
oatmeal mmm well in addition to returns
by Colleen wing and misty Knight from
the first season this trailer also
includes shots of a new villain Typhoid
Mary
played by Alice Eve now type 1 marries
historically daredevil villain she has
associations with the hand this show
will drop on September 7th there will be
10 episodes long as opposed to the
typical 13 episodes for Marvel Netflix
seasons good call though what from this
trailer Sam excites you the most the
fighting immediately looks better at
least a tog Rafi of how they're
capturing it's like hey man you know
what why I don't know why Danny had to
go out there in the open with his shaggy
hair and like in this bad beard like
give him in this shot it's ok but like
another fighting shot that's covering
here and you got a hood on so all you
see is this perfect it feels more
classic to the character you know but
also easier to hide the stunt double so
it can look better and I do like the
jugular it's like we're gonna need some
help and it's like misty and I love
Simone mystic as misty Knight she's
amazing and she's great in Luke 8 she's
one too and in the defenders but like in
like you know Luke's out there you know
Luke doesn't really get affected that
much by the iron fist so and who mode
would be good Jessica as well was super
effective in fighting but I'm glad
Misty's they're all so I guess Danny
kind of or she kind of owes Danny one
with the new right arm so that's cool I
know the fighting looks great and also
the move with the Chi if you guys are
fans of Avatar The Last Airbender or
Korra Legend of Korra that was a move
they would do to take away people's
chief are so they couldn't be benders
anymore that was a move they would do
was energy bending and I was like that's
100% not connected but I just love that
cuz I was like oh if they're gonna play
with Chi that show was based on like Chi
healing techniques and so if they're
trying to at least be somewhat true to
Eastern teachings like that's actually a
really cool detail in there which I
enjoyed and also the actor who plays
Davos he looks like you can actually
fight so I'm on board when he starts
fighting and a red fist looks even
though the goldfish will always that's
the best part of what Iron Fist has
given anyway with the way that looks the
red fist looks awesome
Typhoid Mary I did a some research
recently she's a troubling character in
the sense of Holloway you know Legion is
he does not have multiple personality
disorder or did
I have that it's a different thing yeah
he's schizophrenic but also there's a
chance that he's disassociated with his
own reality he doesn't he doesn't know
how to connect with like act what is
actually happening right because he's so
powerful
what a cool take tie board Mary is she
went through some trauma and she has
multiple personalities there is Mary who
is Mary is just normal she's like
regular old Alice Eve
there's typhoid who is sometimes she's a
mutant like it usually was a mutant and
she has powers and she's more violent
that's the assassin and then there's
Bloody Mary who is like the murderous
rampage II scary one and it's like
that's a really poor way to paint mental
illness especially now it's from a
different time so I understand that so
I'm not ragging on it there but it's
like be careful because where you go and
also she is a mutant she has like
telekinetic or pyrokinetic powers so
that is a cool way to let's see how
Danny's gonna punch his way out of this
one yeah hopefully they'll like with
other things like this like Legion and
like things like splits you know like
there's been some really good pop
culture and cinema that have done this
in a very tasteful way in a very like
in-depth way I think the the point is
just put time into it like put effort
into like fleshing out the character and
developing the character so it's not
just like we're doing it for cool
reasons or it's just oh we can get
something cool out of this like really
dig into the characters like mental
health and how they got this way and
give them true dimension and to see how
they struggle with it and then also that
way you can start to like point in
little things of like this is why it's
science fiction or why it's not just
mental health that's cool yeah it's all
problems that are cool 100% like yeah
and like or she's a demon because mental
illness yeah yeah but also one of the
origins cuz I don't know when I was
reading as a little hard to follow where
the origins landed with typhoid the most
recent iteration of her but there was
one iteration that daredevil is kind of
responsible for how she is the way that
she is and are you familiar with Frank
Miller's daredevil run that's where I
came from and one of the stuff you love
so in the costume the black costume
there is a moment he's going on a
rampage and he goes into a brothel to
get to somebody one of the prostitutes
tries to like get on him he goes this
she tumbles out a window and she dies
and you're like whoa and he immediately
stops everything he
doing and he's like I went too far like
you he went over the board and then it
retcon like reverse like that was her
and so she survived because of her mean
ability and I went on from there it may
be changed now but I thought that was
kind of fun that maybe that could be
another way that I in first ties back to
daredevil to I'm just grateful that like
Netflix is finally doing fewer episodes
wasn't defenders was at 10:00 or was at
eight episodes was eight and yeah
somehow that still felt a little too
much still felt a little too long just
imagine like you know the final season
of Game of Thrones is going to be six
episodes six longer episodes for sure
season seven was seven episodes and
every season before that was ten like
it's as a screenwriter it's it's I don't
want to try to argue for a fewer episode
orders or TV shows because that actually
is bad for TV writers because it means
that there's a longer break between
seasons that you have to like sustain
yourself with the money that you got
paid for the time that you're on the
show but storytelling wise yeah stranger
things was eight eight episodes nine
episodes season two back to eight oh
yeah you don't do your show in the
content favors by getting these long
episode orders I know that the numbers
work out for a Netflix they must because
like this show specifically got crazy
numbers last year before we knew what it
was yeah Scott buck yeah it was
definitely a blockbuster and I think
just that Netflix algorithm of the next
shows gonna start in 30 seconds or
whatever you're just like whatever I'll
just watch it's like the binge culture
favors 13 episode runs because people
just gonna watch it all anyway but yeah
I think you can get much more rich dense
storytelling by just like condensing it
a bit 100% and also I don't know if you
watched season two of Luke Cage Danny
shows up and he has one episode and he
is there they make this great there's a
great line of I was like hey you seem
chilled out and he's like yeah I'm
centered and I can kind of relate to him
a bit yeah but also the season one he's
Danny tantrum 100% he's just like I'm
upset about plane crash parents flying
fists and you're like I don't care this
is 30 you've done this tantrum at least
twice for 13 episodes so if he's chill
and he's just a fighter now and he's
like a vigilante but he has his own take
on it that's different from daredevil
great let's see that I'm on board with
that yeah well again this season drops
on
number seven and let us know what
excited you most about this trailer what
you're most looking forward to and yeah
we look forward to watching it when it
comes out do you think he will be
snapped away at the end of the season
yeah we'll get a lot of you guys have
asked like are these characters gonna be
faded away it sounds like I don't know I
to separate from it what all they do is
reference about on New York what if
Danny finally got redeemed we're like
yeah iron fist he's the bet god never
came back oh yeah maybe Stannis could
snap away half the episodes of all these
seasons ooh Marvel a quick update on the
sequel to spider-man homecoming
spider-man far from home Tom Holland
posted an Instagram video from the movie
set making a joke about how he does all
of his own stunts when in the background
a stunt performer dressed as Peter
Parker is visible getting wiped out by a
giant wave of water now this is actually
led to some speculation over what caused
this attack in the spider-man comics of
course there's a villain known as hydro
man who has the ability to manipulate
water after spider-man knocked him from
a cargo ship but I was doing some like
experiments on the ocean water and
that's Oh Sandman but in cinema they'll
be now if Hydra man does become part of
far from homes plot he will be joining
what sounds like a very crowded field of
villains so it there was a report that
Michael Keaton will return is the
vulture plus possibly Jake Gyllenhaal as
Mysterio plus a new man a car who some
are saying could be playing chameleon oh
boy not to mention remember there's
Michael mandos appearance in the
homecoming post-credits scene as Mac
Gargan Nick a scorpion so that would be
five villains either there's gonna be
like another version of the non sinister
six head are all the villains that are
teaming up against spider-man here or or
there's something else going on but yeah
of those villains which do you think
would be the most compelling I think
okay so one of the cool parts of
spider-man 3 granted but like is seeing
how same man like how he was brought to
life and how he'd fight spider-man cuz
there's not really much he could do
right so seeing an element like that in
this movie pretty cool and Hydra man
funny he turns into a big waterspout
sometimes I think that's fun but it you
know what they nailed having three
characters in the first movie I think
adding two more they
can make it work and if it's just like
side-characters kind of just building
out the world and not making it a direct
threat great do that easy that way it's
like you know that there's threats at
home and threats abroad that are against
Peter Parker yeah cool that does sound
good
when I hear reports of both Michael
Keaton and Jake Gyllenhaal possibly
playing villain I mean those are two
heavyweights like they're both like
Oscar nominated Oscar winning Oscar
nominated at least actors who either one
of them would probably be the primary
villain or primary antagonist so to hear
both of them being part of this movie
plus a bunch and I love Michael mando
from a better call Saul that guy's great
so I think any one of these people could
be a villain on their own but yeah if
they can handle the balance well enough
and you know it's just a wave of water
that we're looking at I mean it could be
anything really just some big falls in
the water and he's next to like Splash
Mountain and he just gets splash that's
all that's classic you didn't have good
footing yeah I Hydra man I had to be
reminded exactly who wasn't like he yeah
and then I remembered Indy there's a
ride at Universal Studios I was
adventure in in Orlando where there's
like you go through when you're like in
the scoop and hydro-man is one of them
so I was like oh yeah he kind of took
took me back Scream is also one of them
you know one of the symbiotes oh yeah it
wasn't the sinister six they just picked
someone that would be cool to see in 3d
because you're sitting in this thing and
they like swipe at you and then any
spray water at you and that those Hydra
man it's a fun ride nice yeah okay well
let's swing from spider-man on the big
screen to the screen you to throw your
controller at when you stupid Mama's go
to bed early we're talking spider-man on
ps4 guys it released some gameplay
footage this week and if you look
closely some Easter eggs in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe showed up spider-man
swings around the skyscrapers of New
York City you can see the sanctum
sanctorum of Doctor Strange as well as
Tony Stark's Avengers tower now this
does not necessarily mean that Doctor
Strange or The Avengers or Iron Man will
definitely appear in the game but pretty
much everyone else is like daredevil and
the Avengers will get reference but
there's also like kingpin and Miles
Morales Norman Osborn and electro and
rhino and everyone's gonna be in this
game but there was that gameplay footage
that we're talking about before we shot
where it was like earlier and there was
like a cliffhanger
what if moment
and spider-man looks up things like you
and there are some theories that it
could be Iron Man because the light
beams onto him
or it could be venom because before
hearing some noises that kind of sound
like venom who else do think might be
that surprised guardians of the galaxy
that's why I have all those lights and
I'm like wait you cuz really why would
you be here here and all and then the
the wusses hooked on a feeling plays and
they just kind of kill all your people
my away super confusing no you could do
no light what is its kind of it because
it's like a light it's like something
bright yeah I think Iron Man makes the
most sense or the Avengers so you could
get like not a Helicarrier but you can
get like a Quinn jet or you could get
like other characters like that they're
coming up with them to take them down or
because you don't see mr. negative in
that shot do you you might he is he's
behind them yeah he's really in that
because you saw him in a couple clips
right yeah yeah it's it's hard to know
because it's also kind of hard to pin
down exactly like we're in the cinematic
and it's not in the cinematic universe
obviously but what how and this releases
the Marvel Universe I think these are
just like settings and locations in that
other footage of what he's on I believe
the raft prison you know so I imagine
they're just gonna be using these things
to populate the world without like
definitively putting where in the
timeline he is someone characters he
might have met her might know I just
assume it's probably for the Marvel
comic so whatever Marvel comic Spider
Man might know it could be in the list
of people who would show up there it
would be cool to see a wakandan embassy
that'd be pretty cool too that was a
tease that someone thought they'd run
again in New York but hey you know I'll
be happy I'm already happy with this
yeah so and that this game looks
beautiful and like it said like you said
it's September 7th I think yeah it's
coming out and that was the same date I
believe what are people's choice there
yeah know what I might be doing I'm
gonna be honest yeah
well let's move on to another update
that actually just came out today the
new Watchmen series on HBO was
officially announced with Damon Lindelof
as executive producer the series will
premiere sometime in 2019 and it will
follow different characters in the ones
that Alan Moore's graphic novel remember
Shaq and the comedian Nite Owl Silk
Spectre dr. Manhattan etc the cast will
include Jeremy Irons Regina King Don
Johnson Tim Blake Nelson Yaya Abdul
Matty in a second
NACO a movie and a ton of other people
but we don't know who they're playing it
sounds like it's gonna be all new
characters but here's the synopsis as
released in the press release it's set
in an alternate history where
superheroes are treated as outlaws
Watchmen embraces the nostalgia of the
original groundbreaking graphic novel
while attempting to break new ground of
its own about as vague as it comes right
HBO announced in a short video on social
media with the iconic smiley face
comedian logo and the tagline nothing
ever ends now nothing ever enters
actually reference to dr. Manhattan's
chilling final words to Adrian
Ozymandias at the end of the graphic
novel who spoiler warning if you haven't
read it
Ozymandias Stasia genocide will attack
that was like a trick to unite the
United States and Soviet Union against a
common enemy and to essentially end the
Cold War and a nuclear Armageddon that
was quickly approaching and Manhattan's
suggestion was that this wasn't really
the end of the war that every event has
unforeseen consequences which we saw
hints of at the end of The Watchmen
where Rorschach had sent out the truth
to a newspaper implying Ozymandias
conspiracy would be exposed
so hopefully this kind of deals with the
aftermath of that it's an amazing
tagline and also if you guys are
familiar with DC Comics going on right
now Doomsday Clock is a story where it's
dealing with Watchmen and the first
issue is about a year after those papers
get published and what happens to the
world because actually it's about like
three years so you get to see that
Ozymandias was kind of right like there
were necessary evil and then they were
able to prove that Ozzy Mannix was
behind all of what he said and it's and
then everything spirals out from there
so that if you guys wanted a story in
between that will have nothing to do
with this Doomsday Clock and also you
get DC characters in there as well
yeah such a great way to pick up because
it's like there's no way things go good
right there's no way cuz it's a big lie
it's an enormous yeah and it's an
interesting ethical debate like well was
it worth it if it just tricked like
these two like trigger-happy nations
from nuking each other I mean how many
people died in New York and it was
different in the in the graphic novel
was like an alien attack yeah in the
movie they just used it as dr. Manhattan
yeah like yeah
I think it's kind of a better idea which
i think is it's simpler exemplar and
it's people can connect with that easier
on the screen I think let's say 9
million I think it was a it was again
pretty much the entire population of
Manhattan yes was vaporized but in the
book it's way bloodier you see like oh
yes basically it's like a psychic bomb
so their brains turn to mush yeah it's
awful fun little tease if you want to
read Doomsday Clock one character is on
basically the outskirts so he only gets
affected a little bit and so it's what
happens with like there's people who are
on the like outskirts of nuclear fallout
where it's like what happens to those
people who didn't get vaporized like
what happened like what's that's what
does that mean so it's like psychic
fallout basically interesting which is
such a great pitch totally gonna watch
this totally on board great tagline yeah
and they have a good team behind it
awesome tagline I love the little
inclusion of the red drop of blood on
the final ellipses dot there but I think
what looking at what the HBO might want
out of this you know they have a game of
thrones' ending you know in 2019 summer
2019 looks like when the seasons gonna
come back we don't have an official
premiere date yet but I imagine we're
gonna be seeing teasers and trailers
during Game of Thrones because they're
gonna try to piggyback this probably off
of Game of Thrones the way that they did
with West's world in its first season
like we saw trailers for during Game of
Thrones and then we saw the the show
come out I think they're looking for
another former lost creator the way they
did with West's world to try to
spearhead this new piece of IP that they
can use to fill the void that will be in
our hearts when Game of Thrones is gone
what do you think so there's I'm
guessing this ignores the movie this is
like this is basically or just like
moves
yeah probably ignores the movie or just
the events of it maybe in for me I
assume it's gonna be taking place after
or in a different part I mean like do
you think it'd be interesting to see do
they go with dr. Manhattan being the
blame or is it alien tentacle evil
hentai psychic thing I'm as much as I
really like Zack Snyder's movie I think
it's a really underappreciated movie
that I would love to do like video about
I think I would imagine everything that
Damon Lindelof has said it looks like
he's going back to the source material
he put out this whole statement about
how he read Watchmen over and over again
with his dad it was like a very like
important thing because I mean the
people who loved Watchmen fans of it are
rightfully he's protective of the story
it's such a
very interesting unique story in the
world of comics and very inspirational
for everything that came after it so I
think he just wanted to let people know
I'm not gonna ruin this you know don't
worry so I would imagine he's gonna go
to the source material as opposed to
building off of Zack Snyder's work yeah
I'm getting chills just from at the
finale of that book is perfect it's a
it's the perfect build up such great
characters read it if you haven't if you
saw the movie trust me it's not like
reading the book yeah oh it's a very
different experience yeah for sure and
let us know your thoughts on this and
what type of characters because we still
have no idea who these outlaw
superheroes will be because I like all
the ones from Watchmen I hope there's
some kind of version of Rorschach in
this story because I love them in that
but we're gonna move on to our new rock
surges and lightning rounds there's only
two of us here today but one and then
one for both of us you guys were great
to tweet some questions I'm gonna fire
them at Sam and he's got one for me and
we're just going to answer as quickly
without hesitation as possible okay here
we go
hold on got em Griffin okay all right
Sam at zak-man 87 wants to know does dr.
strange style his hair with magic or
does he style it with actual hair gel
magic
magic here we go for Erich Fromm at
Bruce gamefreak and several others they
asked who should Marvel Studios look to
direct of guardians vol 3 since Disney
is non-motor reinstate James Yun yeah so
that's we didn't really talk about that
and I rundown but yeah it sounds like
the lease reports are that despite like
talks that they might try to rehire him
they will use James Gunn's script for
guardians of galaxy vol 3 people not
rehire him mmm if you're gonna look for
someone new I know maybe someone who
looks like James Gunn but it's not James
Gunn um
shames Pun hey you should get to higher
but it is actually she was good you can
do something like what Spielberg did
with poltergeist right like sweet burg
didn't get the director credit because
like the studio's wouldn't let him
direct both that and he T at the same
time so we got like his first ad
director to direct poltergeist and that
guy got credit for but realistically it
was Spielberg's movie you could just I
mean James Gunn is gonna be a producer
on it he's it's gonna be his found some
money from it yeah I mean okay Taika
Waititi is obviously everyone's picked
for it he'd like thor ragnarok is pretty
much the exact same tone as guardians of
the galaxy and he's familiarity with all
the characters that would be my pick
it's a pretty good pick all right final
one this is where both of us from ob1
baloney if you take a Batman to lunch
which Batman would you take Michael
Keaton Val Kilmer George Clooney
Christian Bale or Pat flick lightning go
go go one Val Kilmer Michael Keaton is
gonna be a laugh a minute with him
because always speaking of different
voice and I want to talk to Val Kilmer
and be like what have you been doing
since then yeah for real what do you
mean II do know that guys he looks like
a foodie I mean we can agree not bail
though right temperamental in public he
doesn't know how to behave like a person
Oh Robert ray yeah really amateur
played the clip yep okay well now comes
the time for a 15-second shout-out where
each of us both of us have 15 seconds to
shout out plug or ramble about anything
we want Sam okay um hard to say goodbye
new podcast you should check it out
patreon.com slash that's hard to say but
Game of Thrones rewatch podcast I'm
rewatching all of it we're doing two
episodes a week there's 30 minutes to so
it's nice and tight that way you can
just get played quick reviews also our
coast Trisha Hershberger if you're
familiar with her she is reading the has
the books open at the same time so we're
comparing like big moments from the
series as we go every two weeks and you
can watch the episodes along with us and
you can do I do Google Hangouts with us
and you get like there's a and and and
there's a bunch of different things and
we have to hit this goal so we can make
sure that like it's funded for the rest
of the year and if we hit that it's
pretty exciting I'm very excited to get
into this because now I've watched the
series once last year watching again
like when Daenerys walks into the spawn
the very first step alright and I was
like yeah and so it's so cool as a very
like a novice fan to be getting into it
and then my two other coast of watch
this is like their seventh time through
so it's extremely exciting so check that
out sorry longer than 15 seconds Erik
what about you know I just a tag onto
that I I
similarly re-watch some stuff and I I
don't know about you but the biggest
thing that struck me was like how
underfunded the sets were compared to
the latest like the later series seasons
look so like cinematic and beautiful and
it was clear that it was like in its
first season HBO's like we'll give you
some money to do these but you're gonna
be reusing a lot of the same sets and
way more dogs I think that was the
craziest thing to me every episode has
just like dogs
oh the dire wolves they got like big
Huskies it's like now they'd CGI all the
animals its way cheaper I guess the CGI
rather than them because I have to have
like two dogs in case one goes crazy and
I gotta pay a dog trainer but like yeah
that shot where Tyrion wakes up in the
dog kennel I'm like I don't remember
just seeing dogs a bunch of dogs on
camera and no I was surprised of how
often the direwolves would show up and
also makes way more sense on the rewatch
from like how are the dire wolves
growing so much between episodes like oh
it's been months
oh they're growing
it makes sense yeah it's also fun to
rewatch because you realize how wrong in
my case you were when you first watch a
show it's not historical fiction it's
not England and Scotland which I really
thought it was for like three I guess
yeah the wall I guess there's a big ice
wall somewhere it's go for my 15 second
shot out guys saw black Klansmen last
night it's Spike Lee's new movie it's uh
it's really really good I think it's a
very important movie to see regardless
say your politics I think we can agree
that certain hate groups in this country
are not welcome here not a bunch of good
guys good guys but it's like a
interesting despite Lee is you know a
fascinating filmmaker he's very like
politically minded filmmakers so his
characters sometimes when I watch it I
have to like remind myself be like oh
characters don't necessarily speak with
the same kind of level of humanity and
representational acting style it's like
other movies do he all of his characters
are symbols you know so like they're all
serving a broader political agenda it's
almost like kind of watching a I'm about
to say the sound like real theater dork
but a Brechtian style play its
presentational it's it's it's meant to
serve a political point but it's like a
political point that like whether I you
should agree with it like I don't think
there are two equal sides to this one so
now we didn't really have a trivia
question because it's just the two of us
so every kind of works is more but you
know why don't we just do a gif of shame
anyway I want to do one gif of shame gif
of shame shame shame shame yeah so you
could do one to a both do one and I'll
just read the goodbyes as we do the
sandwich window did you have tasks do
the floss dance move to the best of your
ability okay that's the one where it's
like Oh yikes oh yeah for me I have to
non-verbally convinced the tiny angel
and devil on my shoulders to make out
okay so I'll do that as a say goodbye
okay thank you for watching new rock
stars this week this episode of new
rockstars news
I want to thank our host Sam basher and
myself Erik Voss at Sam bachelor a ta
vas you guys I'm verbally non-verbally
comment down below and uh tweet us at
new rock stars like this video share it
around subscribed a new rock stars for
all the deep dives and the stuff that
you love see you next week why are you
two just do it seven minutes in heaven
or hell in that one look at him go
happy birthday